hello everybody uh welcome to my lab
roots presentation
um today we're going to be talking about
chirping method development
specifically for cannabis um
my name is adam floyd i've been in uh
cannabis professionally for about 10
years and
spent about 14 years as analytical
chemist so
terpenes are really my area of passion
and
i've done you know quite a bit of
research surrounding
uh terpenes so i um
wanted to share some of the method
development
tips and tricks that i've learned over
the years and so this project was done
in conjunction with
joel and think 20 laps
before we get too far into the meat of
this
let's take a step back and kind of talk
a little bit about what terpenes are and
why they are so important to cannabis
and so terpenes are a classification of
aromatic compounds
um they're nearly ubiquitous throughout
nature i'm almost positive that terpenes
impact your life
one way or another daily um
you know they're primarily found in
plants but
uh have also been found in marine
organisms and insects
and uh to a lesser degree certain higher
order animals utilize terpenes
they're built from repeating five carbon
units
called isoprene and they follow two
metabolic pathways
in cannabis and there's a tremendous
number of varieties of terpenes
now it's not completely understood
exactly
the role that they play in
you know implants it
there's a lot of evidence that supports
uh
terpenes as a crucial part of plant
growth regulation
uh attracting repelling insects
mitigating fungal growth and a lot of
chemical signaling
um just because it's such a diverse
uh you know category of compounds and
there's so many different
uh variants of it and so terpenes are
also
really responsible for the the sensory
experience
of consuming cannabis flour and there's
a lot of thought too that they
play a certain role in
the medicinal benefits of utilizing
cannabis
so there's this whole concept of uh you
know
this uh synergistic effect sort of uh
this holistic approach to using cannabis
flower versus say
extracted oil or you know a more refined
product so if you go back and look at
like a lot of
uh canvas flower competitions the thc
levels among the winners
typically are right around the same as
the flowers that don't make it into the
winning categories but the terpene
levels tend to be
uh very diverse and abundant compared to
uh you know the the winners typically
have this very
sort of abundant terpene profile versus
the uh
the strings that don't work
so you know when when cannabis science
first started to really evolve there was
so much focus
on cannabinoids and i think largely
there still is and for good reason
um but over the last few years there's
been
this sort of shift towards you know
larger interest in terpenes
and the terpene profiles of strains
and you know like i was talking about
earlier is such a
key piece to the whole sensory
experience of consuming cannabis
i think that people really are becoming
more and more curious
as to uh you know what unique and
interesting
terpene profiles these strings have and
you know they can vary so significantly
from
from one string to another so
i think that there's a lot of traction
that is starting to build
specifically with terpene analysis
so when you make the decision that you
want to analyze terpenes in your lab
um you know unless you're using an
out-of-the-box method which there's
nothing wrong with that
but i find personally that a lot of
times i
like to sort of uh adjust these methods
a little bit to more
suit my needs so if you're starting from
the ground up
it's very important to sort of identify
some uh key ideas and concepts around
your method before you really begin
method development
this can save you significant time down
the road
particularly if you're using headspace
so it's worthwhile in my opinion to kind
of
take a step back before you start this
method development process
and answer a few key questions before
you start
and i think ultimately you'll have a
much easier time
developing a robust and fast method
so the first choice really is is
instrumentation um
i don't have a tremendous amount of time
today so i'm not really going to discuss
liquid chromatography beyond this slide
but um
in general gas chromatography is
sort of the gold standard for terpene
analysis
there is research that's done using
liquid chromatography
i did a tremendous amount of research in
plant metabolomics using
lc orbitrap um but
for routine analysis and
uh you know both in research and
in commercial laboratories typically gas
chromatography is
used exclusively so the idea behind gas
chromatography is that
you know it's an analytical technique
that allows us to separate out
compounds based off of their boiling
point and their chemical interactions
column
once you've decided uh on whether you're
going down the
path of liquid chromatography or gas
chromatography uh you know the next step
is kind of to decide
how many terpenes that you want to
analyze
well there's over 30 000 different
flavors of terpenes that have been
discovered in nature
which is a little overwhelming um
and in cannabis i see a lot of different
numbers thrown out there 100 200
300 but you know it's pretty well
documented that at least 150 different
terpenes have been identified in
cannabis
and obviously this number continues to
grow as we understand this
more and more so it's not really
practical to
analyze 150 terpenes in
a short time frame um i spoke to one
individual that did it and i believe her
run time was right around 80 minutes so
which is potentially fine for um
a research type setting but if you're in
a commercial laboratory you obviously
don't have uh
80 minutes to run every single sample
particularly with
qcs and continuing calibration
verification and so on and so forth
so typically um you know a good starting
point there's a number of
uh commercial mixed standards out there
that
contain 22 terpenes so that's usually
where i advise people to start
particularly with the commercial
laboratory
once you've made this decision then you
can move on to your column selection
and this is important because
here you really need to identify the
goals of your method
and a few considerations for this is the
number of samples that you plan on
running per day
and also a lot of labs particularly if
you're on a tight budget
use the same instrument to run residual
solvents and
terpenes which can cut your
analysis time you know
down quite a bit uh you know there's
also combination methods we can run
residual solvents with terpenes and so
on and so forth
um but if you're utilizing
the single instrument for both residual
solvent and terpene
analysis you most likely want to have a
faster method say under 15 minutes
and then you have to think about your
desired detection limits uh
you know how far down you want to look
uh there's a big difference between
a very sort of robust and practical
method versus
one that gets very very granular and
finally you know are you is this an
academic research lab
is it a commercial research lab or you
know
commercial compliance lab these are all
very important questions to identify
and with that also you have to look at
sort of the samples that you're going to
be running
you know i've worked in cannabis labs
all over the country
and you know the types of samples that
are received
are very regional so in northern
california typically
laboratories tend to be a lot more
flower focused southern california
while there is still of course flower
you see a lot of more products
uh you know we tested dog treats and
feline transdermal patches
and pretty much anything you can think
of to put cannabis in
uh you know we've seen come across at
some point
so it's important to understand this too
is there can be a lot of matrix effects
and
you know if you're running a lot of food
products you may not really
be doing a lot of terpene testing and so
an idle instrument doesn't generate
money
so if you don't have a huge demand for
terpene testing
then it may be a consideration to run a
longer method
with uh with an extended terpene list so
you could provide sort of uh a better
offering to your flower
customers
once you've sort of figured these pieces
out the next step
is to identify your injection technique
you want to use
so there's two primary injection
techniques that are used
for gas chromatography and tripping
analysis the first is head space which
is
you know there's a lot of advantage to
head face and and a few drawbacks and
the other is liquid injection which
is fairly common as well um
so i develop methods on both
uh there's advantages and disadvantages
to
to both injection techniques for
commercial lab setting
i like headspace just because of the
cleanliness of it but
there is also quite a number of
advantages to liquid injection as well
so i would say if you are in like a high
throughput
commercial laboratory say running 22
terpenes i would probably lean
more towards uh headspace
and if you're in more of a research
academic setting or run a
lower volume of terpenes liquid
injection works just as well it just
is a little more maintenance heavy and
another important
thing to identify is the skill level of
your analysts
so assignment um headspace is a much
more
sort of foolproof technique uh whereas
liquid injection can be a little more
complicated
the advantages of liquid injection uh
you know it's a very fast technique
um and another advantage of it is that
sample vials can be re-injected
so this you know with a headspace file
you really
only get one injection i mean there is
formulas to
look at re-injected vials but
i think from an ease-of-use standpoint
it's not really feasible for most
laboratories to do that
the primary disadvantages of uh liquid
injection are that
you know all the volatile and
non-volatile compounds are injected
in the gc which you know with your
your liner can uh cause it to become
dirty pretty quickly
so if you're working in sort of a high
throughput lab
it's difficult to sort of run you know
50 or 100 samples
in an automated manner with liquid
injection
because there is you know quite a bit
more maintenance than
headspace
but one of the you know and then
headspace one of the great advantages of
headspace is depending on where
you are in the country you know certain
states have minimum
required masses for analysis uh
you know i probably wouldn't put more
than 40 or 60 milligrams
into a headspace file to analyze it
directly
you know the idea of headspace is that
you
either analyze you know there's one of
well there's multiple ways that you can
do this but
for interpreting analysis really you do
a total evaporative technique
or direct analysis and so you can just
put the sample directly in there
and you know cook it for 15 minutes and
inject it and it's a pretty effective
technique it's used
widely for uh flour analysis for
trippings and
flowers and flower research now
the problem with direct analysis is
depending on your matrix type you may
run into some
matrix issues oils particularly i did an
entire study on
recoveries from oils
with known concentrations and direct
analysis particularly for the heavy
boilers so i'll put this below
things sort of towards the end of the
list you can run into a lot of matrix
type issues there the other real
big advantage of it is that it's an
ultra clean technique
so the amount of day-to-day maintenance
and you know week-to-week maintenance is
absolutely minimal um when i was working
for brickenhammer
i uh ran into a customer that had been
using the same filament
i think for four years which is pretty
impressive
so it just goes to show you how how
clean this technique is and
you know you get a lot more lifespan out
of your column and so on and so forth
uh one of the biggest disadvantages
really to headspace is that
method development is mind-numbingly
painful
because you have to wait for the vial to
heat up so say
you have a 15-minute incubation time
then you're waiting for that 15 minutes
plus another 15-minute run time
so you're looking at 32 minutes plus
from injection to injection but once the
methods developed you really only pay
that price
first you know with the first sample
most modern headspace systems
uh have staged um
incubation so that's not as much as a
concern as it
was years ago
once you've decided on your injection
technique you want to look at
whether you're going to use a split so
split flipless injections
i think basically all modern gc's for
the most part
um have split surface injection ports
so a split basically allows
for you to only inject a fraction of the
effluent into the actual column
and the the remainder is sort of swept
off
and vented so this is useful
primarily in uh liquid injection
so there's you know you don't want to
overload the column
so depending on what you're doing you
can go anywhere from like a ten to one
split to 100 to one split
uh depends on your sample prep how
concentrated your injection is and so on
and so forth
um footless injections primarily used
with headspace but you can do a split
if you want typically what i do is i'll
adjust the actual injection time on the
headspace unit
setting splits and uh you know basically
when you run into
this injection um the uh this football
just remains closed
so the next phase of this is sorting out
your chromatography
and the separation of terpenes
can be kind of difficult and the primary
reason for that
is that because they are these sort of
five units or
sorry five carbon repeating units of
isoprene um they are structurally very
similar
and uh you know getting baseline
separation
can be uh very important um
obviously it's always ideal if you can
get baseline separated compounds but
you know particularly if you're using an
fid which i'll cover here in a minute
um that separation is key because you're
not
getting any sort of spectral data
so once we've you know separated our
compounds to
uh an adequate level we have to look at
detectors
and so there's only two that i'm going
to cover today that are really relevant
to this
flame ionization detectors or
also commonly referred to as an sid or a
fin
uh it's very inexpensive um i think it's
the most common gts detector in the
world
uh the concept is very simple so the f
movement is passed through a
hydrogen flame and as the
hydrocarbons move across it and burn the
signals produced
oh low cost i think
figs are just a few thousand dollars
typically very simple to use
rugged i mean you can shoot all sorts of
nasty stuff through an fid
and low detection limits and the fids
are also linear across a very broad
range
now the biggest problem with an fid is
the lack of mass collective detection
labs that i know that do run fids
typically have a very long run time
up to 45 to 60 minutes sometimes
so if speed is a consideration i would
strongly encourage you to
look towards mass spec
so mass spectrometry allows uh
you know a much more dynamic style
analysis
there's a number of really significant
advantages here
one of them is also identifying
untargeted terpenes
so say that you calibrate for 22
terpenes or 42 or
45 or 50 if you want to do an extended
list
you know you're still short of that 150
terpene list right and so
you could do sort of semi-quantitative
analysis with mass spec
you can identify these compounds and run
them against it
calibration curve that is you know a
structurally similar compound
well it's not perfect it does give you
an idea of what else is present
in there and you know relative
concentration levels
so here is a uh
some chromatography from uh three
compounds that are sort of
notoriously difficult to separate uh
limonene
cyamine and ostomy and so
you can see there's okay separation
there but they
clearly are co-eluding so
one of the primary uh advantages to mass
spec is being able to
de-convolute this chromatography and
be able to to you know create peaks from
specific masses now one of the biggest
problems with this is that uh because
the
you know terpenes are so structurally
similar you see a lot of very common
masses
uh 69 93 136
all very common amongst terpenes but
there are terpenes that do have unique
masses
which can provide extremely useful
information so now on this slide
you can kind of see the deconvolution of
of the three compounds so
uh limonene has a very intense mass of
68
so you can see that we can deconvolute
limonene completely
from cyamine and also mean 119 for
thymine
again we get a fantastic peak shape and
then
80 from awesome so this is really one of
the great uses
of mass effect so it cuts this analysis
time down
from 30 plus minutes to i think
right i think this method's right around
11 minutes um for the last week to come
out
so it can save you a tremendous amount
of time so if speed is a consideration
of yours
you know again i'm i'm a big proponent
of using mass spec for tripping analysis
so i'm going to kind of end the
presentation with some
uh method validation information
um i encourage both you know obviously
through a commercial lab you typically
have to go through validation
state um if you're a research lab i
think it's very important to understand
the limitations and the other method
so one of the most important pieces of
this particularly in cannabis analysis
is doing matrix-like studies to really
understand
how the matrix interferes with
your analysis and and i say this because
there's
such a broad range of potential matrices
that they come into your lab
so there's all sorts of different
parameters that you can look at for
method validation uh we'll just cover a
few days but
accuracy precision robustness oh ddlq
matrix study so on and so forth all this
really should be conducted
as soon as you're done with your method
so accuracy is is very important uh
it's the closest of agreement between a
test result and an accepted reference
value
so you can look at accuracy with either
a secondary source or a lot number
or a lot of times pt will be sufficient
right it's just a measurement of how
accurate
is is your analysis really and then
these analytical values compare the
theoretical values and
there's a plus or minus window that's
allowed
this varies state by state you may have
internal limitations
uh california is plus or minus 30 which
is pretty generous
i think typically with most of the
methods that i developed
at least initially were typically under
10 for recovery
um and so if you're a research lab
you may say set a stricter internal
standard
through commercial lab plus or minus 30
may be
totally acceptable to you
um sensitivity this is really really an
important metric
you know it's very key to understand
how low you can measure these compounds
one of the the key thing to keep in mind
too is that when you do this
led and loq study with standards you're
measuring your instrument led you know
not an in-sample
led lq um you have to take in
sort of your you know taking your uh
dilution factors into consideration with
determining in matrix so if you're doing
a 5x solution or a 10x or 20x which is
typically what i like to do so half a
gram of material into 10 ml
of solvent um you know you need to take
that multiplication
and apply it to the led and lq
depending on what state you're in they
may allow you to do
repeated injections with the standard
deviation for led's molecules
but most chromatographic methods really
a signal of noise is an appropriate way
to measure this
which i'm actually a bigger fan of that
method
and then selectivity is really important
to understand as well
and this really ties into uh the matrix
effects
and uh you know developing
these methods to separate out
the intended analytes because you have
to keep in mind too that when you're
actually measuring the step in matrix
there may be a whole bunch of terpenes
that you're not calibrating for
that may interfere with this so it's
important to understand that the
data that you're getting back is really
as accurate as you anticipate
linearity of course super super
important metric
with validation fids are linear across a
very broad range
uh mass specs for this type of analysis
you know cannabis flower typically has
between
0.5 and 2 terpenes by weight and
obviously there's a little bit
that goes under and over that but
you know you can calibrate in a range
that allows you to get
probably 95 plus percent of the samples
you know be falling within that
calibration range
i typically never like to calibrate less
with less than five calibration points
and
my square value requirement in
california is 0.990
i feel like a 0.995 is probably a more
um appropriate limit but again that's
either up to you this you know you or
the state and it does vary from state to
state
so i'm going to share a example method
for liquid injection that
i wrote using the joel now it's a triple
quad instrument
but use it in single qms mode so
it's pretty cool um i think the run time
on this
is about 12 13 minutes so it's a pretty
fast
method so you're looking at four to five
samples an hour
which you know is appropriate for the
majority of
commercial labs so please feel free to
use this and
share it all you want
and so in conclusion you know i think
that terpenes really
are such an important and not super well
understood
piece of cannabis analysis and such an
interesting part of the plan itself
i mean certainly in the world of
cannabis analytics this is where my
passion lies
so i think that there's a lot of uh
mysteries and unknowns
that uh still have to be uncovered about
terpenes
and uh you know it's such a cool
aspect of our favorite plan so thank you
so much for
attending and if you have any questions
please feel free to
reach out to me